[Music]  this is my green bean in America's Got  Talent  meet America's Got Talent hopeful Celine  tan the nine year old contestant and her  family might have just proven themselves  as the biggest Celine Dion fans ever I  got a little sister and what's her name  her name is beyond Oh Celine and beyond  not only does solely love Celine Dion  she can sing like her too  [Music]  [Applause]  uh-oh  [Music]  mind you little Saleem wasn't even born  when Titanic came out but this girl can  belt it  the audience gave her a standing ovation  her mom cried even Mel B was swaying  with her hands in the air but we're  going to have to tune in to America's  Got Talent on Tuesday on NBC to see if  Celine has what it takes to make it  through to the next round of competition  you